hell hello South Carolina South Carolina
is hosting the first Democratic primary
with Joe Biden's name on the ballot but
the truth is I wouldn't be here without
the Democratic voters of South Carina
and that's a fact the Biden Camp has
chosen the southeastern state for its
inaugural primary instead of the
traditional Iowa and New Hampshire the
goal is to give greater influence to a
state that reflects America's racial and
economic diversity South Carolina has
one of the high percentages of black
voters in the country a quarter of its
elgible voters are black with a
population of 5 million it's also among
states with the lowest household income
and levels of Education South Carolina
does not have party registration meaning
its primaries are open to all eligible
voters are free to cast their ballots in
the Democratic contest as long as they
do not vote in the Republican primary
Joe Biden is running against two other
candidates congressman Dean Phillips and
other Maryanne
Williamson but the incumbent president
is all but assured of the nomination
though chances that Democrats will take
the traditionally Republican state come
November are slim we need a fighter who
can stand up to the left who can stand
up to the swamp stand up to the media
stand up to the Deep state but results
here could set the tone for the rest of
Biden's
campaign back in 2020 black primary
voters delivered a big win for Joe Biden
giving momentum to his struggling
presidential
bid You're the Reason Donald Trump is a
loser and you're the reason we're going
to win and beat him
again come on despite polls suggesting
mixed reviews of the Biden
Administration among black Americans
Democrats are hoping for signs of the
same success they had here four years
ago how you doing all right still DM
genford Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer